depends on the price but I want to get
as much as I can get you a sample okay
hey man I'm not gonna get ripped off the
first thing I'm thinking is crap a gun
man guns in Mexico I knew that was taboo
they've got strict gun laws down there
nobody but the cops have a gun period
and I'm like and put that away
you know internally I'm already freaking
this guy's my friend I'm going hey Steve
you're not gonna get ripped off he's
gonna burn you for your money all right
just mellow out with the gun thing okay
man all right okay
be right back I'd been around guns I
knew this wasn't the place or the time
for them but he wanted to have a gun
that's fine I knew he wasn't going to
need to use it okay so I leave I go to
Jorge Lee's the guy showed up the guy he
told you about
I said I'm like and Jorge is excited
he's like cool cool yeah let's do
something
you got a shamble I can show sure he
said we need something really good you
know to show this guy because he's got
like you know like $2,000 or something
which was a lot to us and I got a
beautiful sample from unit with you
maybe a half ounce or something you know
to give to Steve that is so sweet man we
were at his hotel room and he's looking
at it he's going while better than the
last would I tell you huh
so I said let's you know let's celebrate
man that's real a couple of these
numbers and then head down to the beach
really nice man really eyes no
terrorists are hanging out in the beach
when it's dark we're smoking
everything's good we're talking he's got
his big plan that huh we had just
finished and remember walking towards
the water a few steps and flicking the
roach into the water all of a sudden
it's very authoritative voice goes what
are you doing here who's that
I don't know that voice I knew it was
trouble man Madison you're not we're
just here you know we're just hanging
out and the guy goes what are your names
where your papers and Steve's going
what's going on man who are those guys
okay just chill out and they walk up to
us and they said Minnesota mismo si si
si tengo tengo I haven't came to almost
policia federal we're the judicial
federal police the bad boys so Steve
goes this better not be a ripoff man and
right when he said that all of a sudden
I'm flashing back to his hotel room
earlier when he says I'm not going to
get ripped off
and I just know it I know what we're not
asking I know the idiots got the gun oh
honey and I'm thinking to myself well I
can't just blatantly ask Steve if he's
got a gun in his pocket and I said tell
me you still don't have that fire
problem in your pocket yeah I do I'm
thinking to myself this is it man we're
going to jail and I'm going okay listen
when I show them my papers and they're
looking at me do something with it and I
pull out my passport they both look down
at my paperwork instantaneously I see
four flashes of light I mean they drop
fast
there was no slow motion Hollywood
crumpled onto the ground they hit the
ground like rocks
I'm in shock
stupid thing to say
do something with it I should have said
toss it get rid of it
God man just one little phrase twist
your whole life around in a different
direction
Steve's already gone he's shot wheeled
and ran before I could come out of my
stupor all this happened within the span
of like two or three seconds I don't
know
time shifted in those situations you go
into shock and time just blurs you know
what I'm thinking it's bad that's all I
can think of this is bad I heard voices
approaching and then I thought I've got
two dead cops on each side of me let's
see oh yeah I better get the hell out of
here